allo mecque des eaux non je te demande
août exactement je t'ai négocier un
créneau mairie excuse moi tu peux
répéter
ils viennent d'annoncer un nouvel
artiste au programme qui devinera jamais
c'est au nom tu vas pas porter ça on
dirait une bonne tu trouves
et voilà c'est notre dernière soirée
ensemble là que je vais aller là xo xo
ça doit être un châtiment pour avoir
déconné dans une autre vie allait bien
oui si dans le cas et si tu allais pan
je suis le roi de son royaume c'est
incroyable tu vas voir ta vie va changer
je dis aux gens ce qu'ils doivent est
mais j'ai vu défiler plus de dj que tu
peux l'imaginer c'est un milieu
impitoyable
plus vite tu t'en rendras compte et plus
ce sera facile
la musique c'est ce qui compte le plus
pour moi je compose parce que j'aime ça
c'est de la vraie musique enfin une
bande sonore pour une pub de voitures
qu'on va vite oublier
et
quand on établit un lien danser avec une
personne c'est comme si on sortait de
notre enveloppe
je me suis toujours vu comme un simple
gamin quand je me suis retrouvé au
milieu de cette immense foule
j'ai eu le sentiment de faire partie
d'un truc bien plus grand
ouais
c'est pas qu'il ya une immense fête
dehors elle est sortie
c'est une grande aventure
on n'est pas venu pour rien fais moi
confiance
tu vas faire une super performance
échalas pour te soutenir
c'est en heure de gloire saisi là
mais j'étais beaucoup de soin
kb
d
m
oui
nous sommes là
d'ailleurs là
juste par l'icône à l'internet
c'est plus
postiga
c'est sûrement mais le garrec